so let me tell you a story so one day  famous mathematician Professor g h Hardy  had come to meet ramanujan the  extraordinary ramanujan in a taxi and  upon his arrival ramanujan asks him that  what was the number of the taxi arrived  in and Hardy simply replaces a boring  number called 1729 but like I said  ramanujan wasn't an ordinary person he  said that it's an in fact a very  interesting number now why is that so  because 1729 is the smallest number that  can be represented as the sum of cubes  of two different sets of numbers so 10  cube is 1000 and 9 cube is 729 if you  add the two results you get 1729 also 12  cube is 1728 and one cube is one you add  these two you get 17 29 so this is how  it came to be known as the Hardy  ramanujan number if there are more  inventions that you are aware of by the  great ramanujan comment down below and  subscribe to don't memorize